NARRATOR: The boats
may look simple,
but their design is
intricate and complex.
Ta'u boatbuilders journey
deep into the forest--
[non-english speech]
--to find the 11
different species of tree
needed to make a [non-english].
Centuries of experience go
into making these boats.
The wood for the keel is heavy,
to keep the boat centered.
The woods used for the sides
are light and buoyant to help
it float.
Only an ax is used
to shape each part,
and wooden pegs hold the
whole thing together.
There isn't a single nail.
It's a real work of art.
[non-english speech]
Building a [non-english]
takes around 5 months.
But with good care, it can
last more than 10 years.
To make sure my [non-english]
survives this journey,
I need to fix those cracks.
And that means heading inland
in search of a rare tree.
The interior of the
island is so mountainous
that most of the forest is
completely inaccessible.
Even the parts the Ta'u can
reach are a tough climb away.
[music playing]
The tree I'm looking for only
grows in a handful of places.
But the Ta'u always know where
to find such a valuable plant.
Finally, I reach my goal--
a tree they call [non-english].
That's gotta it.
They're hard to find.
So the elders, they mark these
trees so they can find them
again, showing how
important a tree like this
is to the Ta'u people.
And what's important
about it is in the roots.
Yeah, right there.
The roots of the [non-english]
tree are surrounded by these
strange, densely packed fibers.
It's like cotton fibers,
really super soft and lofty--
just bizarre stuff.
In all my travels,
I've never seen a tree
that makes that kind of stuff.
Bizarre.
[music playing]
Back at the shore, I get
to work on my repairs.
I need to hammer
the [non-english]
fibers into the cracks.
These tiny fibers, they
act just like the wood.
When they get wet, they swell.
This is the sort of
indigenous technology
that have been keeping people
going out here for centuries--
simple, but effective.
It's all about knowing the
resources that are out there.